there's an interesting relationship
between national security and big
business in the united states biden's
laptop is a hunter biden's laptop is an
excellent example the make and model of
that laptop is an apple
how did they get onto an apple without
the user
how did they do that you shouldn't be
allowed to do that you know what fbi has
long had a contentious relationship with
apple big time
apple won't let them on to iphone san
bernardino yeah the san bernardino
exactly right how the hell did they get
on how do they get on this apple what's
your skepticism my point here is you can
see that apple does not protect your
privacy like they promise that they do
they choose which platform which device
to let who on when
right in this case they let somebody
onto this guy's apple
and in other cases they won't let fbi
get onto an apple iphone that belongs to
a saudi pilot who kills a bunch of
people in pensacola
so there's a relationship between the
government and apple
and apple chooses when to share and when
not to share so this is this this
relationship that you're talking about
with zuckerberg yeah it happens in
social media it happens in all big
government all big organizations
all big companies in the united states
because companies will they get big
enough they have a responsibility to
contribute to national security some
play nicely others play inconsistently
others don't play well at all
so what you're seeing is every company
has to learn it has to mature and evolve
its own position on how am i going to be
how am i going to plug myself in to this
national security context i want to say
we had the guy here who uh uh he had the
laptop john paul mack we had him here
six weeks ago seven weeks ago
and i want to say when hunter brings it
in
the password to get into the computer
was given i want to i want to assume it
was given because he let him log on well
he was working on it that's what i'm
saying so i want to assume i don't think
it was apple uh uh i think the
government can't stand apple because
they don't give the information that
they do because tim cook
uh uh is very interesting guy by the way
tim cook is a very very interesting guy
on how he
uh
works with
the government how he works with
different presidents and who he is first
gay pro ceo of a fortune 500 company to
come out and but at the same time he
had a good relationship with trump and
he had a good relationship with you know
very interesting way how he is but uh i
don't know i won't if it's true it's
true maybe apple gave him the
information but from what i know from
the guy that was here seven weeks ago i
thought he got the password to log into
the system but you you don't have an
apple phone you're not a fan of apple
correct correct all right you're a droid
are you a droid person i use android
mainly because it's the other option
right there's only like two major
options that are out there there's other
options when you get to super high
levels and that's just a personal
preference or there's like a moral
political because no reason yeah it's
because of care if people are killing if
terrorists are killing americans
what kind what business stance do you
have as an american company
to not let
to not help
the fbi solve that case you don't have
to help them solve every case but how
the hell are you choosing to not protect
we can't investigate a saudi arabian
phone we can't investigate a network of
phones that belong to known terrorists
why can't we investigate those phones
right
you obviously have a way to get into the
phone because you guarantee service to
all of your clients so you you already
have a back door we don't need to know
the code to the back door
but but at what point do you decide when
you're responsible for the security of
americans and when do you decide that
you're not responsible for security but
by the way you know we just made me
think about you you just made me think
about so how many how many employees
does apple have 400 000 i don't know
what the number it's a massive number
you mean to tell me none of those guys
on the inside who can't stand a
president on either side
won't
somehow release the password to the
government in a way that nobody will
find out i'm sure they could
i'm sure they could
so there's always leaks so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]